[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROBERT KUBIS: I'm also
a Google Cloud developer
at [INAUDIBLE],, as the speakers
before me, Mete and Mark.
So we understand our ourselves
as software developers
with a license to speak.
Or the way that I like
to introduce myself
is like the bidirectional
interface between you guys, who
develop on our platform,
and the software engineers
inside Google that
develop the products.
So please, please reach out
to us with your feedback,
be it good and bad
feedback, so that we
can improve our products.
Let's go back a little
bit in the history.
And some of you might
still remember these.
I have one of those here.
This little, nice, floppy disks.
And that was all you pretty
much cared about in the '80s,
and maybe in the
beginning of the '90s,
to install an operating
system and install programs
like Word Perfect or things
like that on your machines.
Network wasn't such a
big thing, unless you
were a bigger corporation
that could afford it.
But otherwise, you basically had
your machine and your programs
all on that.
Now fast forward.
Today, this is not
that easy anymore.
We live in a mobile world.
Everybody wants to have access
to anything at any time.
If you develop a
really popular app,
you want to scale
the demand based on,
if people waking up or
playing throughout the day
or the coffee or lunch break.
So applications look more
like this today, right?
They're quite complex,
in the sense of you
have multiple services, you
need some load balancing,
you need some storage,
things like that.
We heard about some
of the offerings
that we have on the Google Cloud
platform in the talk before.
Now, as a developer
myself, I don't
want to really deal
with operating that.
I don't want to look at,
is my app still running?
Do I have to move
my app from A to B
because I do maintenance
or things like that.
All I really care about
is adding more features
and innovating and pushing
them out to my users as fast
as possible.
So how can we do that?
If we look at a little bit
of the history, how apps were
deployed, basically, on
machines or physical hardware
back in the days,
we basically started
with installing the
operating system directly
on your physical
machine and adding
all the apps and dependencies
of these apps to this machine.
Now usually, one app might not
have exhausted that machine,
so you added multiple apps next
to each other on one machine
and they could
interfere each other.
Now, some of you might still
know that term of never
change a running system.
That is from these
days, basically.
When you had that running,
you don't want to touch it.
So that hinders
innovation and, basically,
rolling out new features.
So to get a little
bit more isolation
between your applications and
make it a little bit safer,
in terms of iterating
through new versions,
there was a new thing that
came out a decade ago, or maybe
a little bit more than that,
where we looked at, OK,
how can we abstract
the physical hardware
and actually run your operating
system in a virtual environment
and then just have multiple
on one physical machine?
So that's where virtual
machines came in.
We were basically sharing the
hardware through a hypervisor,
but this virtual machine
still had an operating system.
You still had to install
patches for security and things
like that.
So this still took
quite a while.
If you wanted to iterate--
if you wanted to start up
a new version of
your application,
it still took a minute to
start up the operating systems,
or it took quite
some time if you
had to react to demands
in your applications.
Now, the new way to
do things is actually
to go another layer
above and really
encapsulating only the
things that you really
need for your application
and sharing even more of what
you had before.
So if you look now, you have the
operating system and the kernel
that you actually can share,
and you have the container--
we package our application
in a container.
It's pretty much just running
as a process on your operating
system.
And with this, it's
super lightweight
and can be started and
stopped within seconds.
Now, I have all these
containers which
enable me to innovate and to
roll out new changes quickly.
But as I mentioned
before, applications
are complex, right?
So what I really
want to do is I want
to have a system that helps me
to run all these containers.
And that's where
Kubernetes comes into play.
Kubernetes was inspired by
how we are running containers
inside of Google.
We are running
billions of containers,
starting and stopping
them every week.
Everything runs in containers,
pretty much, inside Google,
in a system that is called Borg.
Now, we didn't want to
open source directly Borg,
because there is
some technical depth.
But what we wanted to do
is, out of what we learned
building Borg, we wanted to
build a system for everyone
who can use the things that we
learned to manage containers.
And Kubernetes was
started from scratch in Go
and was open sourced
two years ago.
And then was one
of the founding--
was actually the founding
project for the Cloud Native
Computing Foundation.
Now, what Kubernetes does is
things like it handles failure,
it manages your containers.
But there are a couple
of core principles
that are really important for
us when we build Kubernetes.
One is we wanted to
meet the users where
they are, in the
sense of we didn't
want to force you to rewrite
your entire applications
completely.
We wanted to make it
as easy as possible
to have your applications
and pour them, basically,
into Kubernetes.
So first step, of course,
containerize them.
And once you have
them containerized,
your containers don't
need to be any special
from running them by themselves
with a Docker engine,
for instance.
Another thing is we didn't want
to couple parts in Kubernetes.
So if you want to
change some things--
if you want to change the
scheduler or things like that--
you can do that.
You can just go check out the
Kubernetes repository on GitHub
and just change the
schedule as you like it.
So it's really about
being open and being
able to have everyone who
uses this system to modify it
in the way that they want to.
Now really, what's
really, really important,
what I'd like to talk
about is that Kubernetes
is about running applications
in a declarative way
versus an imperative way.
So what does that mean?
It basically means you
tell how your application
landscape should look like.
But you don't tell
it how to get there.
Kubernetes will figure
that out by themselves.
And with this, with new
versions of Kubernetes,
you get all the goodies of
how to make this even more
efficient.
Now, another important part for
Kubernetes is supportability.
You can run it on
any public cloud.
We have a managed service,
Google Container Engine,
for it, which makes it
very easy to get started.
It's actually, in my opinion,
the easiest way to get started.
But you can also run
it on things like this.
This is a recipe
of pie clusters.
So I've basically five
recipes of pies here.
I installed an Ubuntu on
this and installed Kubernetes
on this, and I can pretty
much play live "Chaos Monkey"
on this recipe pie cluster,
which is pretty cool.
So if you want to
learn Kubernetes,
this is a good way to start.
Now, the core concepts
within Kubernetes
to run your containers
are actually four
that I want to touch
on in this session.
The first one, first
and foremost, are pods.
Pods is basically
your atomic unit which
moves through your cluster.
A pod basically bundles one or
multiple containers together,
and it moves through a
cluster or gets an IP.
But you should never
talk to this IP
directly because a pod
is an ephemeral concept,
in the sense it can start
and die at any point in time.
Now, to make sure that there
are always as many pods
available as you declared
in your configuration files,
we have replica
sets, or deployments.
And deployments help
you to basically say,
I want to have five
pods of this kind.
And the replica set will
watch that there are always
five pods of this kind.
Now, to make them
addressable, to actually
be able to talk
to these pods, you
use something that
is called service.
Service is pretty much a
load balancer over the pods
that you have available
and routes the traffic
to the pods that are available.
Now, the service
and the replicas
both need to know what
they are managing,
what they are responsible for.
And that's where
labels come into play.
Labels are an orthogonal
concept on top
of this, which you can attach
to any kind of API objects
within Kubernetes.
And then you can select on this.
So basically, a replica
set selects a set of labels
to know which pods
it's responsible for.
Or a service has
a set of labels it
matches to see what kind of
pods to route traffic to.
But this is a lot of words
and I like living on the edge.
So I'd actually like to
show you a little live demo.
Now, every live demo has
to start with some kind of,
what I want to show or run.
So in this case--
I hope it is readable--
I have a Go app, actually.
My language of choice
nowadays is Go.
And it's very simple and
easy to get started with it
when you get a hang of it.
And in this application, I
have basically two endpoints
that you see down here,
where I have the host
name and the hello end point.
And I let this
run on port 8,000.
Now, you see the implementations
of the functions here.
Basically, one I'm just
returning a string,
hello, from GDD Europe.
And for the other one, I'm
actually just responding
with the host name and the
version of the application
that I'm running.
Now, the first step
that I want to do
is I actually want
to build a container.
I want to build this app and
then put it into a container
that I can run on Kubernetes.
That's where Docker
file comes in.
So in Kubernetes, you can
run different engines,
Docker or Rocket are two
of the supported ones.
There might be even more out
there that are supported.
Now, since Docker is
the most popular one,
I'm going to run a
Docker container.
What I'm doing here is
actually something that
just recently came into Docker.
It's a multi-stage build.
Why am I doing this?
Well, if you build
your application,
you need a lot of build tools.
You need your compiler,
you need your linker,
and all the libraries
and things like that.
And your container
would be really big.
But I want to have my
container as small as possible.
So as you can see here in this
first step that I'm doing,
I have my build container.
I am loading my
source code in there.
And then, in the run
command that you see there,
I'm building actually my
statically-linked binary.
Now in the second
step what I'm doing
is I'm copying, from
that build container,
my statically-linked binary
into a so-called Alpine
container with version 3.6.
Now Alpine, the base image
of Alpine is really small.
It's, like, 8 megabytes.
And so even if I would have
bad Wi-Fi at the conference,
I could still do this
demo most of the times.
So let's go ahead and do this.
I'm going to build my
demo here and, as you see,
I have it already
built. But basically, it
goes through all these steps
and builds my application.
Now, I have my
container built and have
my container [INAUDIBLE].
Now I need it to make it
available for Kubernetes
on Google Cloud.
So first, before I'm
going to get started,
I just want to show you in the
upper left, a little command
that you can see there.
That is the command to get
started with Google Container
Engine on Google Cloud.
Key Cloud container
clusters create GDD cluster,
for instance, and then
you wait three minutes
and you have your cluster ready.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I actually
want to push this to
my private registry.
So what I'm going
to do here, I'm
going to push this to
my private registry.
Since I have pushed
that before, it
should be hopefully
pretty quick.
I'm going to go through there.
So now I have it pushed
on my private registry
and I'm going to show
you really quick here.
So this is my private registry.
It shows you the containers that
were pushed, and the versions,
and you can delete them
there, add other text,
and things like that.
So very flexible.
Now, the first thing
that I want to do--
and I can show you that I have
a Kubernetes cluster running--
is that I have three nodes
in my Kubernetes cluster.
Now, I use Cube CDL, which is
basically the magic CLI tool
to interact with Kubernetes,
to run my application.
So in this case, I
use Cube CDL run.
I give that a name.
I point to an image which
I want to run in my pod,
and I want to point
to a port that I
expose for this application.
So now when we do this, I
want to actually show you
what is happening here.
So on the upper-right,
you see, actually,
three API objects that
I'm going to show.
And on the very first, you
have the pods that are running.
And now we have our version
one of our demo app running.
But the second one is all
the services that I have
and the third one is all
the deployments that I have.
Now, what I don't
have right now is
I don't have a way, basically,
to talk to my application.
So I have to make that somehow
available through the outside.
And that's where
services come into play.
So what I'm going to do is I
do a Cube CDL expose, which
basically gives me
the chance to expose
my service either inside the
cluster or even to the outside.
How do I make it
exposable to the outside?
That's where dash dash type
load balancer comes in,
which basically tells
Google Cloud platform,
please provision
a load balancer.
Next to a load balancer and
make that application available
outside.
So you're going to see there,
I have now a service coming up,
demo app, with a cluster
IP, which is my internal IP
and an external IP
is pending because it
takes a little bit of time.
Now, you might want to
back your application.
So what I'm going to
do is I can actually
exec into my container.
In this case, I
have to, of course,
use the ID that you see in the
upper-right corner on the top.
And I'm going to do
and execute bin bash.
And now, in the lower one, you
see that I'm in the container.
So I can do LS, I can do a
PS, and see what's running.
My app is running.
I can even do a wget q0 and say
HTTP slash slash local host.
8,000.
And say hello.
And you see, OK,
hello from GDD Google.
So that works.
All right.
So this gives you a possibility
to go back and see what's
going on in the container.
Now, the next thing I
want to do is-- actually
what I can do with this.
I want to see if it's
now externally available.
And you see we have an
external IP over there
on the right side.
So I'm going to copy this
external IP really quick,
put it in here, and run this.
And this just
refreshes every second.
Now what I want to do
is, with Kubernetes, it
makes it very easy to
actually do rolling updates.
So you push a new version
of your application.
So what I want to do
here, in this case,
I say, OK, you are an awesome
crowd because the audiences are
always awesome.
I'm going to save this.
And I'm going to go back
to my shell and build this.
So I do a Docker build.
And in this case, I want to
have, of course, a new version.
So let me go back and
do the version two.
I'm going to build this.
Now you see I actually
made a change so this
takes a little bit longer.
So you're just going to wait
for a second till that is done.
And once it's done,
I can now push that
to my Container Registry.
So I have Key Cloud Docker.
Push.
And now I push version two.
And now we wait
again a little bit.
While we're waiting, with
Google Container Engines,
you have a lot of things that
are managed for you by Google
that, if you run
it somewhere else,
would have to manage yourself.
So things like you can
now do outer scaling,
you have all the money
touring [INAUDIBLE] created.
The [INAUDIBLE] is supervised
for you and things like that.
Now, I want to push
out the next version.
And before I want
to do this, I want
to show you really quick
how easy it is, actually,
to scale an application.
Now, you have the Christmas
business coming up
and you want to scale
out your application.
So you just scale
the deployment.
As you see on the upper
right, there is-- right now,
I have desired one.
I'm going to scale that.
And you see, coming up on
the right, two new containers
and we are live.
And you can see that we
are live on the top-left,
as the host name is changing.
But we still have version 0.1.
So what I want to
do really quick
is actually edit my deployment
and go to my version 2.
So this is the configuration
file that you see here.
I just changed live, in
my configuration file,
the version.
And I'm crossing fingers
that it will work.
And you can see it's
terminating version 0.1.
Now it's running version 0.2
and, as you can see up there
on the right, it actually
did the rolling update
of my application.
All right.
So this, hopefully, gave
you a brief introduction.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
This gave you, hopefully, a
brief introduction in what
Kubernetes is capable about.
But what I'm really delighted
and excited about to have here
is Steffen from Flixbus
who can actually
talk about how to implement
Kubernetes in production
and talking about the
experience of running Kubernetes
in their company and how
it enabled them to innovate
and grow really, really quick.
So let's welcome Steffen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEFFEN HANKEL: Thanks, Robert.
I'm Steffen.
I am an engineer at Flixbus.
Let me just talk to
you about what we
do with Kubernetes
at Flixbus and how
we use it in production.
First, who is Flixbus?
So I think 200 of you actually
got some vouchers from Flixbus
and traveled here by bus.
So that's really cool.
So we are a long distance
bus travel company.
But we're actually
not a bus company.
So even though we have around
1,500 buses on the streets,
we don't actually own
any of those buses.
So you can it compare
it to Uber model.
We're just doing
all the marketing,
planning, booking engine,
but we don't actually
operate those buses
and we don't actually
employ any of those bus drivers.
So we cooperate with
small to mid-size bus
operators for that.
We have pretty good growth.
Our first commit was
in December 2011.
Now we have around 40
million passengers this year
and that's an estimate.
And at the bottom, you see the
graph of our stack uses an IT.
When I joined the
company two years ago,
we had around 50 people there.
And now, altogether,
it's like 200.
Not all engineers, but it's
challenging to grow that fast.
So how did we start?
We built a big monolith
made of all of PHP and MySQL
and a bit of Memcache and all
the other external services
you have.
And all the developers were
working on this big monolith.
This became a problem because
we want to grow the teams,
we want to grow how we work,
we need more engineering power.
So you cannot only work
on the single monolith.
So what do you do?
Well, you pick the
newest fancy solution
that is called
self-contained systems.
And basically, it
means you split up
the teams and the code and the
code base by business domains.
And every one of those
self-contained systems
might be multiple micro
services that work together.
But it also means,
of course, splitting
the code base, the data model.
You need a messaging bus.
You need to handle
data migration.
You need to have new teams,
new responsibilities,
so there's a lot of
challenges doing that.
And one of those challenges
is infrastructure.
So we used to have a
two-person team managing
our infrastructure.
And this worked pretty fine.
Over the years, it
got pretty stable,
but of course, that's not
a sustainable solution,
especially if we want to grow
the number of applications
that we have.
So the small and
simplest team resulted
in that high communication
that every time you
needed to do something, you
needed to talk to this team,
and hey, please can you do that?
Please, can you operate
PHP to this version?
Please, can you
install this extension?
Please, can you--
I don't know, do
something else there.
And we were running
on bare metal,
and this makes it really
hard to do system upgrades.
We were two years behind
on a deep-end release.
Because there were more
important things to do.
And of course, at some point,
you cannot scale your system
anymore.
So of all these [INAUDIBLE]
velocity of new application
and services.
So we need to change that if
we want to do micro services.
And our goals when picking
a new infrastructure,
looking for a solution there,
we had a few goals here.
And one was that it
needs to be reproducible
and unified [INAUDIBLE] mind
for applications, including
development.
So we had a lot of
different vacant boxes--
people were moving around--
which were not up to date
with the staging environment.
And we had, of course, our
production environment,
and it's hard to
keep that in sync.
So containers are a
really good fit here
to make them all
the same version
and have them all be consistent.
All the teams must be able to
demonstrate their environment
quickly and independently.
This is really
important so teams
can-- if one team
wants to save his PHP5
and the other team
wants to go with PHP7,
it should be hey,
sure, no problem.
And we want it to
be future proof.
We don't want to redo
everything every two years.
And the ease of use was
also really important
and also [INAUDIBLE]
independence.
So Kubernetes is a
really great fit here
and I could talk about a lot
of great stuff in Kubernetes.
For example, pods.
They're a great model to
model entities in a cluster.
Robust access control is
another really great feature
to reduce overhead.
The deployments are really
amazing in Kubernetes.
Authentication models
are really good.
But also, the strong API in the
ecosystem and the community,
I think, makes
Kubernetes special.
So let's talk about how you
can use the API to build
your own great applications.
So in February 2016, we were
dabbling around with Kubernetes
and there was no
ingress controller yet.
Ingress control is a way to
specify how to get traffic
into your cluster.
So we wrote our own, and it was
basically 100 lines of Go code.
Now it's around 200
lines of Go code.
And it's running
some production.
We want to get rid of
it, but of course, it's
always hard to get rid
of temporary solutions.
And basically, this is
how the code looks like.
We connect to Go.
We connect to the HTTP server,
to the endpoint, and say,
hey, what's true?
So please give me
all the updates.
Every time an endpoint
changes, please
give me all the new endpoints.
And we do some more of
the open reader for it
and what you get
is, if you open this
Go to connect to
this endpoint, is
you get a JSON object
per line in this thing.
So we read up to a
new line, we decode
the JSON object, we put it
through a templating engine,
put it to a directory
on the disk,
and we basically reload Nginx.
And of course,
there's not a lot of--
all the error handling
is missing there,
but it's actually still working,
running production for us.
And this basically took
an afternoon to write.
Another great part is the
community of Kubernetes.
So we wanted to
incorporate Kubernetes,
or the authentication
part of Kubernetes
with open ended connect
to Azure Active Directory.
And it seems we
[INAUDIBLE] because there
was a bug in how the
validation was working.
So we submitted
a buck and we did
some of our own investigation
and found the corresponding pod
in commiter source.
There was a fix en
mass seven days later.
And another six days later,
they gave us a new release
with the fix included.
So that's basically 14 days
from reporting the buck
to getting a new
release that we could
deploy in our infrastructure.
And usually, you pay a lot
of money for this, I think.
But with Kubernetes, you
just get it for free.
Another pod,
deployments in the API.
We tried various approaches
to deploy applications.
Some developers use Cube CTL,
some use Jenkins, some GitLab
CI.
We tried a bit of Helm.
But one of our
developers said, OK, this
is all not working too well.
I think I can do this better.
And he started doing that
and he created Deployer,
which we use internally.
And the cool thing
about Deployer
is that it creates a new staging
environment for every branch.
So in the past, we
always had this problem.
Hey, can I deploy my code?
So we do 70-plus a day in
the old system, on average.
And people want to
test their changes
on a staging environment.
But if there's no one
free, then you're blocked,
and we don't want
to block people.
So now we have one staging
environment per feature branch.
And I'm going to show
a quick demo for that.
So please switch to my laptop.
OK, perfect.
So I have a very simple
application here,
a Docker file with Nginx.
And we're basically just
exchanging the index HTML file
there.
I have a YAML file with all the
Kubernetes definitions I need.
So we specify a service,
we put some stuff here,
some labels that we need
for our custom [INAUDIBLE]..
So you probably want to use
a ingress controller now,
ingress resource.
And we have a deployment.
And basically, we
do some templating
to get the dynamic stuff
into our YAML file.
We have to deployer file.
It's a bit like [INAUDIBLE] CI.
We were looking into those
things as an inspiration.
And [INAUDIBLE] hey, OK, what
class do you want to deploy to?
What name space?
What containers are there
that need to be built?
And we configure GitLab CI
to build our containers,
push it, and then
trigger the CI--
deploy our CI pipeline.
Let's make a change
here in the HTML file.
I will create a new branch.
And now it's 1307.
I commit the file
and say, hello, GDD.
We push it.
So with the CD mass of
branches already employed,
everything works fine
and the demo gods
listened to my prayers.
Then we fill a new deployment
here in your service,
so there it is.
So the new deployment
has a new-- basically,
it's all in the same name space.
They have a new prefix.
I'm going to give it a few
seconds because our open lens
is throttling, like reload.
So we might need to give it
a bit of time so it works.
This is the master
branch, which still works.
OK.
So I'll open it.
It probably still needs
a bit of time to reload.
And there it is.
So you get a feature branch
for every-- or environment
for every feature
branch when you're
developing, automatically.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Let's go back to
the presentation.
So these things all
fit very well together
and help us solve our
problems that we have.
Because every company is
unique and sometimes you need
to change things and there's
no one-size-fits-all solution.
And Kubernetes really
gives you the tools
to help solve your own problems.
So what's the current status?
How does our
infrastructure look?
So not everything is
running Kubernetes yet,
but we already have
around 60 names
spaces for around 12 teams.
At peak, that was like 800
containers running on 32 nodes.
And we have mode production
services running there,
including two mission
critical events, which
push around a 100 megabit
of traffic at peak level.
So Kubernetes really helped
us solve our problems.
For me personally,
I think Kubernetes
is one of the most exciting
projects, open source
projects, in the infrastructure
space since the Linux kernel
itself.
There's so much support in the
community and just great stuff
going on.
You should really look into
it if you need to solve
or [INAUDIBLE].
So thank you.
If you have any
questions or want
to chat with us about
Kubernetes, the Flixbus
stack, or Google
Cloud, you can find us
on the third floor at the Google
Cloud Platform office hours
after this talk.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]